How the British Empire tried to solve a problem and accidentally made it much worse.
Explained like you are five.
Step one, it is 1800 colonial India.
The British are running the country and Delhi has a problem.
Cobras.
Venomous cobras everywhere.
In the streets, in the homes, killing people.
The British colonial government decides to fix this.
Their solution?
Pay people money for every dead cobra they bring in.
Simple, logical, efficient, kill a cobra.
Get paid, fewer cobras.
Problem solved.
Except the problem is not solved.
The problem is about to get significantly worse because the British forgot one thing
about human beings.
Give people a financial incentive, and they will find a way to maximize it.
Whether you intended that or not.
Step two.
The bounty works at first.
People go out, hunt cobras, bring in dead snakes, collect money.
The government is pleased, but then something unexpected happens.
Entrepreneurial Indians realize something.
You do not have to hunt cobras in the wild.
You can breed them.
At home.
In boxes.
It costs almost nothing to keep.
It eats very little.
It produces eggs constantly.
And every single one of those eggs hatches into a bounty.
So people start cobra farms, hundreds of cobras, thousands of cobras.
All bred specifically to be killed and exchanged for British money.
Step three.
The government notices the bounty payments are going up.
Way up.
Far more cobras are being turned in than could possibly exist in Delhi.
They investigate.
They find the cobra farms.
They realize what has happened.
So they do the sensible thing.
They cancel the bounty program.
No more payments for dead cobras.
The cobra farms are now worthless.
You have a shed full of cobras that earn you nothing.
So the farmers do the only logical thing.
They release all the cobras.
Thousands of captive bred cobras.
Released into the streets of Delhi.
The cobra population is now significantly larger than when they started.
Step four.
The British colonial government tried to reduce the cobra population.
Their solution created a cobra farming industry.
Designing the solution released thousands of new cobras.
The problem they tried to fix, now worse than before they tried to fix it.
This is the cobra effect.
When a solution to a problem creates a bigger version of the same problem.
It happens because the people designing the solution think about the goal.
But not about how people will respond to the incentive.
And people always respond to the incentive.
Not the goal.
Step five.
The cobra effect is everywhere once you know what to look for.
Vietnam under French colonial rule.
Same problem.
Same solution.
Same result.
The French paid a bounty on rat tails.
People started rat farms.
When the bounty was canceled, rats released.
More rats than before.
In 1990s America, schools were measured by test scores.
So teachers started teaching only to the test.
Test scores went up.
Actual learning went down.
In the 2000s, banks were rewarded for giving out as many mortgages as possible.
So they gave mortgages to anyone, good or bad, and created the 2008 financial crisis.
Step six.
The cobra effect has a name now because of an economist called Horst Seibert.
He wrote about it in 2001, but the pattern is ancient.
Every time a government or a company or a person creates an incentive, someone somewhere
will find the most efficient way to satisfy the incentive.
Not the spirit of the incentive.
The lettering.
The gap between what you measure and what you actually want.
That gap is where the cobra farms are built.
The British Empire had the most powerful government on earth and they made the cobra problem worse
by trying to fix it.
So next time someone offers you a simple solution to a complicated problem, ask yourself, what
are the cobra farms?
You can find more details and many more stories on Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers.
Try it now and become the smartest in the room.